That says office and you need to set of
scissors,
if I remember correctly,
that one has to imagine him happy.
Well,
if there's a rock at the bottom of the
hill,
then you might as well push it up the
hill and if it rolls back down,
well then you've got something else to
do.
Don't you can push the damn rock back up
the hill and there's no shortage of
rocks to put up to push up the hill and
that's what we're built for anyways,
and so let's go out and like push them
down,
boulders up the hill,
and then maybe we could have enough self
confidence and enough enough respect for
ourselves that we wouldn't have to turn
to hatred and revenge and try to take
everything down because I think that's
the alternative.
So he's not weak.
That's one thing you can say about them.
Same idea represented there,
right?
That's outlets who voluntarily takes the
world on his shoulders.
It's like the idea of Christ taking the
sins of the world on his shoulders.
It's exactly the same notion,
which is the notion that you should be
able to recognize in yourself all the
horror of humanity and take
responsibility for it because that's
what that means and the thing that's so
interesting about that is that if you
can recognize yourself in yourself,
all the horror of humanity,
you will instantly have a hell of a lot
more respect for yourself than you did
before you did that.
Because there's some real utility in
knowing that you're a monster now.
And just because you're a monster
doesn't mean you have to be a monster.
But it's really useful to know that you
are one.
So the and,
and one of the things that you knew,
and this is something that I find so
amazing about his writings and I think
something that really distinguishes
them,
for example,
from Joseph Campbell who talked about
following your bliss,
is like young said very clearly that the
first step to enlightenment is the
encounter with the shadow.
And what he meant by that was everything
horrible that human beings have done was
done by human beings.
And your one of the.
And so if you don't understand that and
to understand that really means to know
how it was that you could have done it,
and that's a shattering thing,
to try to imagine that,
to try to imagine yourself as someone
who's engaged in medieval torture,
to see how you could in fact do that.
You're never the same after you learn
that,
but being never the same after learning
that is unbelievably useful because when
you understand that,
that's what you're like,
then you're a whole different creature.
And I don't think,
and this is something I did learn from
young,
is that you cannot be a good person
until you know how much evil you contain
within you.
It is not possible.
And it's partly because you just don't
have any potency.
Like if you're just naive,
if you're just nice,
if you'd never heard anyone you'd never
heard of fly.
You don't have the capability for any of
that.
Why would anyone ever take you?
Seriously?
You're,
you're just,
you're a domestic animal at best,
you know,
and uh,
rather contemptible one at that.
And it's a very strange thing because
you wouldn't think that the revelation
of the capacity for evil is a
precondition for the realization of
good,
but I believe,
first of all,
why would you be serious enough to even
attempt to pursue the good unless you
had some sense of what the consequence
was of not doing it.
You.
You have to be serious about these sorts
of things.
It's not a.
it's not a.
it's not the game of a child,
right?
It's the game of a fully developed
adult.
And you have learned this in part when I
had little kids,
I wrote a chapter for my new book called
never let your children do anything that
makes you dislike them.
And why was that?
And I read,
I read that,
wrote that after I knew I was a monster
and I thought,
I'm going to make sure I like my kids.
I'm going to make sure that they behave
around me so that I liked them because
I'm way bigger than them and I'm way
more cruel than they are.
And I've got tricks up my sleeve that
they cannot even possibly imagine.
And if,
if they irritate me,
I will absolutely take it out on them.
And if you don't think that you're the
sort of person that would do that,
then you are the sort of person who is
doing it.